non alors sur la formation alors sur la
question des règles de sécurité du
contrôle des autorités c'est faux non
seulement il n'y a pas de sanction il ya
que la chasse est une impunité complète
sur les accidents de chasse non mais
attendez regarder les condamnations je
suis avocate je suis bien passé pour
voir il ya donc une nation il ya les
noms et l'iphone avis il ya souvent des
relaxes et le problème souvent qui se
pose c'est que les règles de sécurité ne
sont pas fixés au niveau étatique ou mal
fixés ou très insuffisante ça donne lieu
à des relaxes que l'état a complètement
délégué tous ses pouvoirs aux
fédérations de chasseurs et que l'état
est complaisant que ce soit au niveau de
l'état du haut niveau des départs des
débuts tout dans des préfectures on a
une vraie complaisance avec les
chasseurs qui sont en fait les
préfectures se retrouve des chambres
d'enregistrement par exemple pour les
questions de battues administratives
les battues administratives sont
demandés par les fédérations de
chasseurs le préfet signe comme une
quête commune de chambre
d'enregistrement et en fait on se
retrouve avec une situation où les
chasseurs font la loi mais c'est
absolument insupportable
[Musique]